bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy hablaremos del rol que eeuu
ha interpretado como mediador de paz
entre israel y los países árabes estamos
en el umbral de una nueva era
quiero prometerle que todos y cada uno
de ustedes a través de sus ministerios
serán parte de ella porque esto va a ser
una paz diferente la gran emoción que
existe en el país también se refleja en
la gran emoción en bahrein y los
emiratos árabes unidos y entre el pueblo
en general
acaban de ser históricas las decisiones
de normalizar las relaciones
diplomáticas entre israel y los países
árabes bahrein y emiratos árabes unidos-
cabe recordar que desde 1948 con la
creación del estado de israel en el
territorio que los palestinos ocuparon
por cerca de 2000 años el mundo árabe le
declaró su profunda hostilidad no sólo
se han embarcado en la guerra de 1948 la
guerra de los seis días de 1967 la del
líbano las intifadas y los incesantes
conflictos en la franja de gaza también
han seguido una serie de esfuerzos de
paz poco exitosos que no han logrado
superar décadas de desconfianza y
violencia pero un actor indiscutible en
la geopolítica del medio oriente es eeuu
un país que ve a israel como su mayor
aliado en la región tras la caída del
sha reza pahlavi en iraní la llegada del
fundamentalismo islámico en 1979 a la
nación persa eeuu perdió su posición
estratégica de cara a su enemigo de la
guerra fría la unión soviética de manera
que concentró sus fuerzas en apoyo
israel y el primer gran paso fue actuar
como un mediador de paz con uno de sus
enemigos árabes egipto en la guerra de
los seis días de 1967 israel no solo
había diezmado más de la mitad de la
fuerza aérea egipcia sino que había
invadido una gran porción de su
territorio en la península del sinaí la
bisagra entre oriente y occidente así
que en 1978 el presidente estadounidense
jimmy carter fue el mediador y el
anfitrión para que tanto egipto como
israel saldarán sus diferencias todo
comenzó el 9 de noviembre de 1977 cuando
el presidente egipcio anuar el sadat
visitó jerusalén y pronunció un discurso
en la knesset el parlamento israelí su
discurso eclosiona va la voluntad de paz
que se esculpió en washington un año más
tarde en la residencia de los
presidentes estadounidenses camp davis y
allí el nombre de los acuerdos en los
cuales anuar el sadat de egipto y
menahem béguin premier ministro de
israel firmaron el cese de hostilidades
y la reactivación de actividades
diplomáticas económicas
y culturales sobre esta paz entre egipto
e israel escuchemos al sobrino de anuar
el-sadat quien fue asesinado en 1981 así
como a un empresario en las calles del
cairo
la paz con israel quizás se considera
una paz fría y sigue siendo una barrera
psicológica entre nosotros y el pueblo
israelí esta es una realidad tangible
yo soy
el ex presidente anuar al sadat tuvo que
firmar los acuerdos de camp davis era
una situación neutral pero muy difícil
para un presidente frente a un gran
número de ciudadanos y en condiciones
económicas y militares difíciles tuvo
que utilizar su juicio subjetivo y
reconsiderar el acuerdo más de una vez
hizo lo correcto ir a la acción más
razonable en ese momento porque no
estaba en guerra solo con israel sino
también con eeuu de américa 16 años
después en 1994 israel logró hacer las
paces con un segundo país árabe jordania
en este caso el mediador fue bill
clinton un acuerdo de paz entre el
primer ministro de israel isaac rabín y
el rey hussein primero de jordania
pese a lo impopular del acuerdo dado que
gran parte de la población jordana es
palestina otro de los esfuerzos
estadounidenses de esa misma década de
los años 90 fue el de la paz entre
israelíes y palestinos los llamados
acuerdos de oslo de 1993 reunieron a
isaac rabín con el líder de la olp yaser
arafat ambos estrecharon la mano y
marcaron un camino reconciliatorio un
acuerdo fallido dado que en 1995 un
extremista judío asesinó a isaac rabín y
la paz se diluyó en una terrible
intifada palestina en el año 2000
y cuando firmó el acta de paz en el
césped de la casa blanca en septiembre
de 1993 dijo a los palestinos que
estamos destinados a vivir juntos en el
mismo suelo en el mismo país
ya en el siglo 21 george bush hijo fue
el primer presidente estadounidense en
llamar a la creación de un estado
palestino que cohabitarán con israel la
propuesta de bus fue apoyada por su
aliado arabia saudita y presentada en la
liga árabe de naciones en el año 2002
siempre y cuando israel se retirará de
los territorios ocupados en la guerra de
los 6 días como los altos del golán en
silla la franja de gaza y cisjordania
desde entonces el líder palestino mahmud
abás se sentó a negociar con los
primeros ministros israelíes hood volver
y ariel sharon pero desde la llegada de
benjamín netanyahu de quien se dice es
el primer ministro más derechista en las
últimas décadas en israel la paz está
atascada
hace apenas unos momentos recibí una
llamada muy especial con dos amigos el
primer ministro benjamin netanyahu de
israel y el príncipe heredero mohamed
bin zayed de los emiratos árabes unidos
donde acordaron finalizar un acuerdo de
paz histórico todos dijeron que esto
sería imposible
bahréin emiratos árabes unidos egipto y
jordania cuatro países árabes que han
normalizado relaciones diplomáticas con
israel bajo el manto de los eeuu pero
aún son varios los vecinos en medio
oriente que le declaran su profunda
enemistad a israel algunos son siria
líbano irak irán y por supuesto el
pueblo de palestina así llegamos al
final soy andrés suárez jaramillo
gracias por compartir estas historias
que las encuentran en france 24 punto
com
[Música]